after the election Boris Johnson
promised to help revive the dying towns
of Britain particularly those who
switched to the Tories after voting
labour for decades but the government
faces an uphill task in doing this not
helped by Mothercare finally closing
down all these shops last weekend
debenhams closing 19 stores this week a
Marxist Spencer in the middle of a four
year plan to shut a hundred shops with
toys arse British home stores and PAL
more already gone what one retail
analyst called this carnage is bound to
continue and even accelerate in town
after town once booming retail centers
are now dominated by charity shops cheap
food outlets and empty premises if they
want to revive the spirits in these
towns the government is going to have to
do something about the state of their
high streets to do this we've been
creating more jobs in these towns
overall making sure rents and council
tax for commercial properties are
reduced and even slowing down the
ever-increasing growth of online
shopping I wish the government luck but
I don't make their chances of success
[Music]
Greg um I'm just sad to say I think
you're right I mean I don't see a way
back from this because consumer behavior
has changed now and particularly for
young people you know when I think of
when I was a teenager what you did was
you went to the shopping centre a
weekend and you hung out and you sort of
spent your pocket money and now they are
going to shopping centres but they're
not shopping the way we did they're
going to chicken shops and so I think
that perhaps what's going to have to
happen then you've got the threat of the
Amazons and the sort of online retailers
what's going to happen is we're gonna
have to redesign what the high street is
for you know there's a great quote which
I'll read in a minute from Sir John
Timpson and what he talks about is then
becoming hubs
for the community where that's a place
where we go to interact with each other
but the idea of the high street being
so for consumerism I think that's gone
and we need to decide what it's going to
be instead I think that's probably right
the difficulty is getting from here to
there and how do you well I mean first
of all there's a lot of pension funds
and people who have invested it I'm
gonna go fast investments in high
streets yet rents are gonna have to come
down yeah we counsel wait I mean
business rates are probably gonna have
to come do have to come yeah but that
means that money has got to be replaced
just to stay where we are
yeah not let alone do what you want to
do which is to reposition the high
street but I'm sure that's right at one
way you could try to influence the
behavior could you only skate it over
online Greg Amazon just don't pay enough
tax look at their turnover last year was
it 2.3 billion and their corporation tax
went up four point seven million to 40
million can I have their accountants
please because that would be very
helpful and also these councils that are
crying wolf to the government saying
it's your foot what are you going to do
about it they're the ones that allowed
all the supermarket's to go out of town
with parking and they're the ones who
are still fleecing shoppers with high
parking target it's a lack of
imagination very local authorities
attacked just as a point of that
information Amazon would say they pay
legally they pay shortly what we do to
balance pay yeah as would Google that's
what yeah as what's domiciled in
Luxembourg they say that the intensive
and I would have thought what you said
but actually the truth of the matter is
only 18 point six percent of sales are
actually done online it's still nearly
80 percent it's done installed in shops
but I think then what's happening then
well well I'll tell you what something
it's we've got your profit the last 20
percent in most businesses that's the
profit I think you're right about
bringing rato because I think we have to
decide what we want the high stripped of
TV and I think I think a lot of people
in my area
there's a million coffee shops I swear
to God every time an ordinary shop shots
a coffee shop replaces and why is that
because people want community they want
to talk to each other they want to mix
so there's an amazing place in York
called Bishop's Thorpe Road and it's not
in a posh part of York and
that's all individual little shops and
and a couple of years ago in the worst
recession ever they got together and and
they they they open one website and
Ravana and they relaunched their street
they put a bunting and and within half
an hour three thousand people were there
eating drinking party so now their
street is a place to go
people linger on that Street because
they want to be there because it's
social yeah but are they shopping and
yes they are there's lots of delis
there's lots of cash there's butchers
that raise them in a short products
that's because that's the thing that's
been lost backup cameras point on that
there's if we if we look at the number
of people that prefer to spend their
money in independent local retailers
rather than big chains we can see here
on the screen it's fifty-six percent
actually fifty six percent of people now
I live in London in East London and so I
have the benefit of that advantage
because of course it's easier to do that
in certain communities in London
especially in East London but if you are
where I was born in a coastal town in
Southend ancien Essex it's harder
because of course you've got that you've
got a few obstacles in the way of that
and I think actually you're right we
need to reimagine what we want from the
high street then we need to bring in the
incentives whether it's lower business
rates or other forms of encouragement to
get independent retailers but I am
wondering though will it primarily end
up as just food people want to go to
they want to go buy their the screws in
their nails at the traitor you know Mary
Portas said a thing when she did the
thing on the high street a couple years
ago she said you know we sacrifice
community for convenience and that's
exactly what we've done because big
supermarkets sprawls big out-of-town
shopping centres we we took it away and
we encouraged that we wanted them so
it's up to us to bring it back actually
and one of the hammer blows for local
community shots I think about where I
was brought up in Swindon on the council
estate my mother used to go and get her
pension with my father every week in the
post of it what did the government do in
its wisdom yeah
they paid it directly into people's bank
accounts that post office at all its
local merchandise has closed down and
the entire shopping Square has now gone
it's not it's quite easy to be doing tax
enjoy
thinking and government and local
authorities have to get faster I mean
what's interesting is that in a lot of
the poorer towns this has been going on
for years yeah it's interesting that we
were discussing it now including me
because we don't live in those towns
Boop but it's it's finally caught up in
the towns we live this is John Timpson
obviously he's done remarkable things
for the high street and he's also the
chair of the high streets expert panel
and he says we need to put people back
on the high street to do that we need to
put to put back in there what people
want and need leisure medical services
libraries all the things that will make
sure people go into town and meet other
people so what you're saying my worry is
that we're losing that sense of
community and actually human beings
needs working out ways how to get huge
numbers of cars through quickly in huge
numbers of people what they need to be
doing is finding ways to make us - it's
interesting your figure you said about
1990 boy online actually the football
the fool in in football along high
streets in the last 10 years is 20% it's
virtually well that's what happened
these are fixed costs businesses and all
your profits the last 20% if you're not
getting that 20% down no longer
profitable now then how can you change
that well you've got to change the
business relation you've got to change
the myth that might help yes that might
I've talked to traders near where I
lived going on some why are you going
and they all say because the rents going
up coming death don't you also think
some of these department stores need to
get with it if you go into certain house
of phrases is like being in grace
brothers in are you being so charming
but a lot of young people don't really
relate to mr. humphreys are you free I'm
straight it's had it's there you go into
some of these develop CIL's two floors
empty nobody there it's deserted and
they've got to find a way to right now I
know one of the big owners of these
stores is are they're looking for what
else can you do with them so they're
talking to theaters they took into
cinemas without saying look we've got
more space than we know
okay wow that note it's time for us to
take a quick break you are watching the
pledge on Sky News up next how can we
persuade more people to adopt
[Music]